turn the tides
we must give back chance my ancestors
the thunder strikes
as the sea demonics swept through the
lands of the fiery likeness of landau's
fire
tearing apart livelihood
the mounting waves and erosions leave my
island gaping like the mouth
of a dead fish
tens muscles of uncles and aunties
that hauled cement for the sea wall cook
meals for the hungry bellies
release
and relief
the tides have gone out
i look
to my grandparents graves
intimate
with limp seaweeds
the disrespect
my name is selena lam
at 18 at the cop 21 alongside late
ambassador for climate change tony de
brum
i introduced myself as a small island
girl with big dreams
five years later i reintroduced myself
as a climate warrior from island gaynar
the marshall islands
situated between hawaii and australia
our chain of islands decorate the
pacific ocean like seashells and they
are home to about sixty thousand people
our islands average above two meters
above sea level
and it is not uncommon to see both the
ocean and lagoon side from wherever you
stand
we say our highest point is the bridge
which curves about seven meters above
the sea
the massive body of water is our reality
and our livelihood
with a history of seafaring the ocean
connected our islands together as well
as providing many resources to fish
to feed and to adorn our handicrafts
with seashells that we make
a living from
but the climate crisis has brought
calamities to my people
threatening our very livelihoods
in the pacific
king tight season is from november to
april this is when the tides are at
their highest and each year the sea
level rises
in these months especially houses by the
seashore end up flooded or damaged
completely
schools and churches have had to open
their doors for community members to
come sleep at when announcements come in
the radio advising to find shelter
because of incoming tides
and we huddled together with our
blankets and pillows
no matter that we are strangers as we
sleep next to one another
sea walls are rebuilt as soon as it's
low tied only to be broken down again
by the waves that grow higher each year
and these waves
their path continues on into the islands
bringing with it garbage we've thrown
into it
you see the graves of your loved ones
submerged in water
littered
then the vegetation starts to brown it
is dying
the soil becomes salinated
you pray the bigger trees hold on for
their roots are needed
to prevent further erosion
in the most affected parts of the land
the land has regressed
coming closer and closer to the road
each year
our driest part of the year happens
within this time period too
we are unable to use ground water well
because it becomes saltier as well
in the capital medieval once per week
water is dispensed and my neighbors and
i fill up our tanks
our water catchments
our bottles and our buckets
our government has had to declare a
state of national emergency
calling for help from our friends
sea level rising flooding droughts
erosion have been the reality of my
people for many many many years
we've been told to move
to become climate change refugees
i'm not even sure who would even take us
in but to those who think that we can
just accept our faith i want to say
adaptation and indigenous knowledge
are the solutions
these islands are our ancestors our
predecessors
our homes
we are at the risk of losing all of that
for something we contributed very very
little to
raising and expanding the islands
is something my country
is thinking of
however we don't have the resources nor
the infrastructure
regardless
we remain adamant
we continue to fight for our livelihoods
and not abandon our home
thank you
common
you